foreign
you know one of the things that's
happened in the last week or so as
President Biden signed into law the new
secure act if you want to see a full
uh breakdown of the secure act we've got
a great article coming out on our
website at the end of the week so be
checking our blog at the end of the week
and it's going to be absolutely
everything you need to know about the
secure act but there's two things in the
secure act that were signed that uh a
lot of it had most of it had to do with
retirement but two things they did that
were very cool
um that are helpful on this other issue
one is the law allows companies to make
401K matching contributions based on the
employer's student loan payments
even if the workers don't contribute
directly to their own 401k
so
apparently if I'm understanding this
correctly
um a lot of people a lot of companies
are helping with student loan debt one
way or another out there it's a hiring
process you know it's a hiring thing now
a signing bonus type thing so like
you've got a match on your 401k that's a
reason to go to work for that company
we'll help you with your student loans
the reason to go work for that company
so they're making this happen here and
if I'm understanding this correctly the
company can make contributions to your
401k equal to up to three thousand
dollars a year I believe it was equal to
your uh your payments on your student
loans
this is the same president that's
forgiving the student loans I'm so
confused but um they're not forgiven so
there we go
and um yeah this is the thing so
employers can match your student loan
payments with retirement contributions
this is correct uh uh here I mean I'm
trying to read the thing let's say you
get a new job making a hundred thousand
employer matches three percent on
contribution but you're still working on
getting Sally May out uh your employer
could offer up to three thousand dollars
I was right about that yeah so you put
three thousand dollars down on your
student loan they'll put three thousand
dollars in your retirement account if
your employer offered that it is now
legalized with security that's pretty
cool yeah there's a reason to do your
debt reduction you know reason to get
there and the other one that's even
cooler uh because a lot of people gripe
about well if I put money in the 529
what if we don't use it
well number one that almost never comes
up because very few people put enough
money in the 529 for this to be a
problem okay but let's say you've got
thirty thousand dollars left over in
your 529 and you didn't use it number
one if you didn't use it because of
scholarships you can take out every year
the value of the scholarship so if you
get a ten thousand dollar scholarship
you can pull ten thousand dollars out of
your 529 no taxes no penalties you just
have to provide the documentation that's
already on the books but the secure Act
is allowing if after all of that you
still end up with because you went to a
cheaper school and your parents had
saved like maniacs okay and you end up
with money left in your 529 you can roll
it
after 15 years you can roll over any
unused money from a 529 to a Roth IRA
for the plans beneficiary
so uh Little Susie Q your daughter has a
529 and little Suzy Q
doesn't use it all 15 years later Suzuki
can have a Roth IRA and roll the money
into that with no penalties this is so
exciting to me that's a really good
thing yeah especially as a parent I mean
that's a discussion we've had in our
house and just a conversation and a
thought process and it's like wow that
is a huge change for parents well it
takes away the whining that says I'm
afraid I'm gonna have too much him I
thought I'd do anything which never
freaking happens but it could happen
hypothetically and if it did number one
if it's because because of scholarships
you should have pulled it out right then
and not paying taxes doing what we just
told you that's already on the books but
now this act the secure act signed by
Biden thank you President Biden good
good piece of legislation here I think
everything in this piece of legislation
but one thing I like we'll cover that
another day but these two student loan
things one is the employer can now match
what you pay down up to three thousand
dollars into your 401k nice benefit and
two this one's even more important if
you had 529 money left over after 15
years you can roll any unused money from
a 529 plan into a Roth IRA
the student to the student okay not to
Mom and Dad's Roth IRA but to the
student's Ira which is this is just very
cool yeah just it's another way to set
your kids up for success and again like
you said to take those excuses off the
table
there's not a reason not to save for
college if you're in baby step five you
know and you think your kids are going
to go to college like that's a great
thing to do and you don't have that fear
anymore there's not that reason to
hesitate